this is Val Val she was born in 2013 at
the National Zoo in Washington DC he or
she is biting her foot he or she is in
the snow and he or she is in a jumbo
sized FedEx crate bound for a one-way
trip to China in China Bao Bao left
because she was never ours to keep her
parents may Shelley and Tian Tian came
from China 17 years ago but they want a
gift they were alone and that loan
stipulated their offspring will also
belong to China as do almost all of the
pandas in this worldwide pandas natural
habitat exists entirely within the
borders of one country and that means
these animals are more than just mascots
for China they're also tools in China's
global diplomatic strategy
[Music]
what trying to figure it out as it kind
of became more of an international power
in the second half of the 20th century
was that this is something that could
use Swift advantage pandas have been
part of Chinese foreign policy since at
least the 1950s initially it was just
kind of given in the same way that you
know governments have usually given
exotic animals to others he gave pandas
to its allies then after pandas
officially became endangered and that
looked kind of patchy they started
giving pandas as loans in return the
receiving zoos pay 1 million dollars per
panda each year in fees and if a cub is
born use paint extra cub text of
$400,000
the thing is that kind of doesn't give
pandas to any country that can put up
the money for a loan it's much more
selective than that researchers at the
University of Oxford have noticed the
correlation between panda loans and
China's international trade deals so in
2010 China realized that it needed to
find more market capacity to buying
manage they are traditional trade
partner Norway had been kind of the
Nobel Peace Prize have gone to a Chinese
dissident China didn't feel like
rewarding that behavior so instead they
turned to Scotland which also produced
salmon also produced Land Rovers which
was something else
the Chinese affluent class if we're
interested in and so they into that
trade deal and a panda was sent to the
Edinburgh Zoo
but what China gives it can also take
away consider the case of Taishan Baba's
older brother from DC China had made it
known toward the end of 2009 that it
wanted to take back the Panda Tai Shan
it hadn't really set a date yet
officials at the National Zoo asked
China to extend its day but the answer
was no experts suspect a couple of
factors were involved in that choice one
President Obama met with the Dalai Lama
who is a strong critic of the Chinese
government and a fierce advocate for the
independence into bed which could
chinese government denies and second the
u.s. announced an arms sales to Taiwan
over Chinese objection a week later
Tyshawn and another pamphlet from the
Atlanta zoo were on their way to China
it considers pandas as kind of another
arm of diplomacy in the same way that in
the event of a diplomatic spat one
country might recall its ambassador or
might impose economic sanctions China
sees or certainly appears to see from
the way that its agreements go pandas as
kind of a way to reinforce international
relationships that it's building and
that it wants to continue more recently
we saw trying to delay a panda delivery
following the disappearance of a
Malaysia Airlines plane carrying 152
Chinese nationals in 2014 Malaysia was
already to get its first panda they had
the enclosure ready at the zoo and all
of that and the day of the pandas toads
arrival came and went because the
Chinese government was extremely
frustrated with the Malaysian
government's investigation of the flight
didn't feel that it was doing enough and
so kept the pandas for another month or
two as a way to demonstrate to the
Malaysian government that yeah you know
we find every trade deal with you we're
interested in pursuing a relationship
that you're not making us super happy
right now currently the u.s. still has
12 pandas including bow bells new little
brothers bay bay but future relations
with China could change that it's
entirely possible that whether in a
military respect in the South China Sea
or in a political respect with regards
to Taiwan that China will find good
reason to feel that the u.s. is no
longer interested in pursuing the kind
of warm partnership that they've had so
what that means for panda diplomacy is
really anyone's guess
you
[Music]